I don't know. It just feels,
I feel bad for the people who physically like can't control the gambling.
Yeah. I mean, I, I do, but they should not be playing games like this.
And I feel like,
I feel like these games should really come with a warning to take time.
Exactly. It should come.
They should be like heavy warnings of games, I think to like, say, Hey, listen,
you can spend a grand and come out with PNGs. Like, what was that?
What are you looking at? Sorry. Okay. Sorry.
Let's you'll be like a heavy warning saying, listen,
you can progress vendor grant for like an animation,
the P and G that gets you a little bit of serotonin. Like,
that's it like no money involved, like gambling totally fair. That it's like,
well, I just, it angers me so much. How, like.
I don't see the value in those. I mean, that's, that's,
that's just the new generation. Right? What would you want to pay for it?
You want to pay for more money now I'll pay for a little bit.
I don't like often I never had people like defending gambling gods. Right?
They're just like, yeah, dude. It's it's what it is. Gambling is what it is.
You go in there and it's and yeah, if you want to go and waste your money,
don't waste. You want it. But in Gacha everyone's like, Oh no,
actually like it's, everyone's like, I guess,
cause the option there is free to play, but.
Because there's no free to peak play gambling.
[inaudible].
Ashley, some good customer casinos will give you free drinks. You just turn up,
get a free drink. Let's go. I guess that's the equivalent of free to play.
Right? I'll have an orange juice please. No gambling.
That's the equivalent of like free tentpole today. Yeah. And they are generous,
but I guess people, if you don't have a gambling addiction,
you can't understand how it feels to have a gambling addiction. And I get it.
Why some people might just want to play a game.
Don't know that it has like gambling in it maybe, essentially.
And then they get like kind of tricked into it.
Cause they've been weaned on the game.
And then that's, that's just modern apps in my opinion, because,
because we've just found a way to literally hack our brains, like human beings.
Like we, we, we like to think that we're not predictable. Right. But how,
how have like five, 10 years ago? Can you imagine like,
just like having most of your life have most of my life now is scrolling down on
something. You know what I mean? Most of my life, when I'm talking to you guys,
I'm scrolling down on some kind of time.
Yeah. I guess we'll get into some philosophical stuff here.
But back to the point of catch-up right?
The other thing that we've done is that we've done the best thing that we could
ever want for these companies. We've Mimi spending money we've cause every,
nobody wants to feel bad, but wasting $200 and not getting what they want.
So what do you do? You go to Twitter,
you tweet out how you didn't get anything and you pick like the pain pill pack
or whatever it's called.
[Inaudible] that's like a dad trying to
[inaudible]. Is that Peyton pecker. Oh, that is, that is our POG champ.
[inaudible]
Oh God stop.
Meaning about me being a boomer for one second. Listen,
we have all like trick each other into making gambling,
like a community event and like enjoying it. Yeah.
Because no one wants to lose alone because we share the pain. Right.
And we share the same pain picker we've done.
What exactly what these companies wanted us to do,
which is make like the gambling into like a form of acceptance.
Like you're not truly, you haven't joined yet. You haven't joined the gotcha.
Unless you get a thousand bucks and haven't got the one with thick thighs.
You forget about three months later.
No. Are you telling me that part of like the gambling experience?
Like you go into a casino. I remember the last time I went to casino with you.
Great time, because you got to, you egged on Eugene, like loses money.
Hilarious. That was funny. Eugene's our friends. Um,
so you basically did the exact same thing.
Well, what happened was is that I, you know,
at the time he didn't have a job and we were telling him, you know,
you probably shouldn't be spending your money. But I was like, you know,
I kept playing, I didn't lose much like a hundred bucks.
I was spending that much and he wanted to keep up with me. And I was like,
if you want to, you can go ahead.
I don't know, man. That sounds very suggestible to me. Anyway,
I'm going to get the reverse psychology. Right? It's like, it's like,
I'm going to do a 10 pole. I mean, you don't have to do it. I just
[inaudible].
Yeah. I'm not sitting. I'm not streaming me going to a casino. It'd be like,
Hey guys, let's gamble. And blackjack, hog man got blackjack. You know.
If the equivalent equivalent of that, I mean, it is. I mean, like I said,
gotcha.
A wife, you could see, you know, stream gambling. Is that poker?
I know Jack, can you.
Is that there's pretty heavy rules around it though, right?
There's not heavy rules around Gacha no, I guess why not? Why not?
Should that be, should that be? I don't know. Honestly, should be.
I think there should be some regulations.
I feel like the biggest thing about Gacha is that people should know what
they're getting themselves into. Um, people should know a lot of things.
That's why that's why people should also have the option to tell casinos, Hey,
can you ban me? Because I have no self control.
There's no way to do that with catch-up.
And unfortunately I like to see is that,
is that an option with casinos in every country? You can do that. You can,
you can basically.
So what you're saying is we need to come up with like the Gacha police.
You visually need something,
you need something spending too much money. I am dead serious.
Be something on the light play store, something that you can be like, listen,
I gambled too much.
Can you please not allow me to spend more than like a hundred bucks,
like a year or something like set it hard limit that there's no way to turn off.
I agree with you with that. Because if you go to the casinos,
you fill out the form says, please ban me from this casino.
They will never let you in ever like,
because they have like a database and a lot of the time, if you, uh,
I think sometimes some courts require you to do it for certain occasions,
but it's very popular and common that people who gamble too much to what they
want to get that life on track. You know, because it's,
it's easy to have a lapse in like willpower and you go to the casino. Yeah.
So if 95% of the time, you're like, I'm never gambling chastity belt themselves.
Right. Basically you can say like, this is not good for me.
I'm going to fill out a form. I didn't know.
You can do that in the UK a hundred percent because it's gambling is a huge
problem in the UK for like betting shops and stuff. So they'll, they'll do it.
And you can basically, if it's a chain as well,
they'll ban you from every chain. I'm not sure.
Well, but like I, I do, I do think you're talking about a, like a vast minority,
cause like most of the people who I've met, who have,
who are playing gotcha games. They've they're not like, no, no,
they're not like us. Right. But for us, it's kinda like, like for me, at least,
you know, it's, it's kind of like, it kind of revolves around my job.
You know what I mean? You stream.
You stream. It gets views. Right?
Exactly. But like for most people that I know that play. Gotcha.
They haven't spent like an inordinate amount of money on it.
But like,
I don't think there should be an ability to ruin your life for falling animate
girls though. Because like we know Taxstone, who's a popular, uh,
Gacha game streamer. And at one point he used to play, what was it? Um,
Summoners war. He nearly like, I think he went homeless.
He legit went like finance. He like,
I think he might've filed a bankruptcy or something.
He went fully broke from Gacha games.
This should never be a thing that should never be him telling me.
Like, it was like a,
like one story that should never be a thing for casinos either. Right? Yeah. No,
but I mean, there's more, I agree. There should be more regulations about it.
There needs to be a gotcha police. That's all we need.